[Music]
see we are back with another edition of
the gentleman's dojo we're here and
actually this is kind of interesting for
us because we are not in our typical
Burbank studio no but this is if we're
not in the code you know it is the first
time we are taking the show out on the
road yeah but it's for a very special
reason very a very special reason
joining us today we have a comic an
actor a game show host he's done it all
Steve you know this from Jane elsewhere
Bobby's world Deal or No Deal America's
Got Talent a star in the Hollywood Walk
of Fame
everything Canadian Walk of Fame as well
we want to welcome our guest to the show
we're so excited to have this guy the
one and only Howie Mandel is Howie
Mandel here Wow thank you for having me
and thank you for leaving Burbank and
yes your you've gone West we've gone
West to Van Nuys yes yes yes
this is not I would not have expected
this is your production office it's
absolutely beautiful yes very cool I
don't know that it's beautiful but it is
a production office everything green
eyes it's very very cool yes this is
Howie Central yeah we first of all your
friend rich helped us out in setting
this whole thing up and so we agree it's
funny Steve and I Steve Maison is
sitting in for Steve Byrne this week
here at the dojo I'm gonna sleep awesome
years off promoting Steve our buddy
Steve Byrne who co-host the show with me
has a new Showtime special out right
called tell the damn joke which is
coming out this Friday right so he's out
promoting NASA's no he's out and you're
here promoting that I'm your dog because
I have to UM but here's what's so funny
so I couldn't have thought of anybody
better to do this podcast with me than
my buddy Steve because Steve and I know
you in a very unique way in a sense that
Steve and I both did audience warm up on
a GT my video he and I did a very
beginning deal or no do the very very
beginning Wow Reaper shows you did the
pretty much like you will you remember
it was like 15 hour days or oh yeah
they'd open the case would be like well
now let's try it this way
yeah well they were always we never
change I got to be clear they get
reopened a case no no yeah yeah yes yes
but it was 15 hours because they wanted
that show was about people's reaction
right so what it was is if they have to
make a decision they'd have me and I
didn't mind walking around ad nauseam
going are you sure this is we're not
absolutely beautiful you can say no they
really want and the drama got out the
drama but for the warm-up the drama was
how do I keep and also on America's Got
Talent
which in the audition process people
don't know is also a 15 16 hour day so
to warm up is to beyond warming up it's
to overheat to overcoat and to just take
an audience and really to make a warm up
person is really well it's interesting
because I was living in San Francisco
doing stand-up and I came down to LA to
go see a taping of The Tonight Show with
Jay Leno and before I went in there I
found out that your daytime show was
filming right next to Jay Leno
this would have been back in what 9999
right so I remember we came in and I saw
your daytime show and that was when I
saw my very first warm-up guy and I
think your warmup might have been like
Phil stellar Robert Cox somebody like
that don't really remember but I
remember seeing this guy come out do a
few jokes bring you out and the show
started I was like that looks like one
of the greatest gigs I've ever seen you
ought to do it and as a result of seeing
your daytime show back years ago it
inspired me when I finally moved down to
LA to do warm-up right so it was it was
so crazy because I would like to think
that you were somewhat responsible you
and your show for getting me information
yes yeah which was awesome
Steve and I will both tell you this
which is kind of funny you gave us both
amazing kudos when we hear you're such
an it's so so fantastic when we over at
AGT when we were in Houston you're
having dinner with some the executives
in front of them you said hey listen I
know how hard that job is I know this
that the other thing and you said that
to Steve as well I couldn't do that
I couldn't do it for the amount of hours
that you know like you said when you
walked into my talk show yeah you know
the warm-up guy would go there like 10
15 minutes before we're going to go up
just as so that right get warm and
that's what I always thought was
traditional
warm-up and then the two shows that you
mentioned that I did Deal or No Deal
right and America's Got Talent the
warm-up guy it's like the it's like
being in purgatory yeah you know because
it's like we want them laughing we want
them cheering just for another hour just
for one more hour is there any way we
can keep them laughing and cheering
after lunch is there any way we can get
them to dinner to [ __ ] it right that you
know warm up the comet is the
connotation is warm them up and then
something will happen like this is just
I need them cooking but you are the
crockpot of Mohammed yeah in those two
shows you know with it and let it simmer
all day long and then when you get back
you got a show well Stephen I said that
one of the hardest cakes to do is a game
show because they want a hundred
different reactions it's a long day
who's in Oz that can be a very long day
so that's the that's the downfall but
you were always so nice but Steve and I
have always said because I never came
back to a GT after your nice nod Steve
never came back we do G yeah once I give
us a car because of the earth it's the
Grim Reaper tones like we say oh we
heard a we're about to fire the warm-up
guy when you go over and say something I
something I remember when they I
remember because Steve said to me he
said how we call me over and he said
what a great job of Osgood and then you
never made it back there was I did one
more day and then that was and I thought
I was like listen mister the show
instead i'ma do good I remember I've
always assumed that you guys quit I
swear no no no it was really unfortunate
even when I said I just want to cover up
because again I don't want to insinuate
anything about like when I said the
cases I just went I was there like at
the very beginning of Deal or No Deal
yeah when it was like they're figuring
out where do we want the cameras we want
like right we want her walking down this
quickly let's write again slowly so it
was that stuff you'd be doing over and
over so over so one show was taking like
sometimes I think I'm like 12 hours to
get through the whole absolutely show
absolutely and so but I remember we were
we we finally took a break after one of
these long times and I did like a you
know we have all these paid audience
members that kind of thing and they're
getting tired but you know half of them
they all live here in LA they all got
have some talent so I always on these
breaks get them up and they do like
impressions
dancing do something you know what I
mean so all of a sudden
I have these it broke out like it was it
was like the Jackson 5 there's there's
four of them on stage and they're
dancers the backspin and doing all this
stuff and I look over and and how he
would come back in and I think you were
there I want to say John Melendez is it
John big comedy goes up mendoza
john mendoza you yes John mendoza was
there right and I remember him I was
like oh my god this is you know from the
one about one of my I was growing up
seeing him and uh you guys walked in and
and then you purposely came over you're
like this just fantasy you you're doing
a great job this is this is one of the
best things I've seen and then I so my
confidence was really high and then like
this in two days later two days later
you know what I don't like that but I
don't think but I don't think you got
fired I think what happens is that
people have friends yes of course you
know we are in the world of nepotism
right whether it's a family member or a
friend and the reason they weren't there
right at the beginning it was they
weren't available and when their friend
becomes available right their friend
comes on because these are well-paying
jobs and there's they're few and far
between so what I find is you end up
finding like how did you get this job
well I know well I know one of the
producers and what do I do sir and
there's no and you guys aren't under
contract also as soon as a friend
becomes available yeah that friend is
there for the check you're exactly right
because we all we all know I mean Gary
Gary's deeper into the warm-up than me
that that tend to have almost any show
has one warm-up guy at the beginning for
three or four weeks guys for the first
month and then it settles into one
person that ends up taking it from from
that point on hey Frank you don't know
that juju like you said it's funny I
want to ask you something about your
daytime show because when I came down to
see it I just remember just being just
blown away because I never really seen a
show tape before good endeavors let's go
you look you must look at not like the
landscape there's so many different
daytime shows I mean is that would you
want to jump back into something like
that or that was then and well I'll be
totally honest with you I do love that
format that was not a good time for me
personally and I'll tell you why because
I had been filling in for Regis many
times and they said oh you should have
your own show you know and it was fun
because I was like I didn't have a boss
you know and I didn't have
anybody to answer to so I would go on
that show and at that time it you know
it was Kathie Lee right and me and
Kathie Lee would have a great time and
the ratings would be really great and
they said you got to do the show
you got to do a show and I said okay
I'll do a show and I went into daytime
and I had a friend that was going to
produce this way I talked about nepotism
and another thing I had a friend who had
produced a lot of my HBO comedy specials
in that and then this woman and I said
she'll produce it she's produced
television and she knows me and then
they said to me that this is the first
you know when I look back the first
marking on the one they said no you know
we want somebody who has done daytime
we're not going to have your friend
because that it is a niche it is a
different audience right is somebody so
now I had an executive producer who was
not kind of in tune with me and then it
was about you know
then they said shave then they said take
out the earrings yeah then they said
wear a suit then they said you know
you're going to do all these makeover
you know I'm really not interested in
makeover and right I mean right now that
you couldn't you couldn't tell them but
I have no interest in hair but but you
know and and cooking segments and I'm
really not interested in how they do the
scenes on soap operas but you know they
kept saying this is the daytime audience
this is the female but you know
ultimately you got to be true to
yourself you know Ellen is true to
herself and that's why it's successful
you know Rosie the people that really
Rose in those Oprah they have their
really Judge Judy is just herself and
that wasn't me and I fought it all the
time and I used to say to the to the
executive producer say you know if you
can give me one thing if I blow it or I
make a mistake or something goes wrong
never yell cut because that's when I'll
be at my best and that's when I'll be at
my you know that's who I am right now I
like those ladies rough rough edges and
I like being the person who maybe
stepped into the wrong room or stepped
up the wrong see and I can't tell you
how many times you know I'd hear cut cut
they go with a pencil rolled off your
desk and I go
it doesn't really matter and if that is
a problem then coming well we're rolling
and tell me the pencils off the bat
right I'll go look it up and maybe
something will happen because it's got
to be real and that's the farthest from
real I ever was right you know and they
wouldn't allow me so that was when it
was over I was that's why regardless of
anything you ever see me on Deal or No
Deal age et wherever I am and I love I
love doing all those shows but my
favorite and most comfortable place is
always stand up because there are no
marks to hit yeah there's no editing to
be done it's my primal scream at the end
of the day right really hard my whole
entire life it's been really hard for me
to fit into the confines of any rule
yeah you know I don't have a GED
I didn't finish school so I will abide
by rules you know I'm a parent and I am
a husband and I've been with my wife for
40 years you know I can live you know
and I don't get speeding tickets and I
can live within the confines of rules
and I love doing America's Got Talent
and I love the allure No Deal I never
had bigger success than that but the
truth be told it's really the depending
on what confines and restrictions you
put on me and that was professionally
the biggest most restrictive thing Wow
so I would love to appear on a daily
show whether it be nightly or daily or
or whatever if they allowed me to appear
as me you know even when I got Deal or
No Deal it was a big you know
controversy whether I should wear my
earrings and I just went you know I
really don't give a [ __ ] about my
earring right but I'm not going to start
there I'm not taking them off right and
it was just like I'm not taking them off
yeah I'm gonna be you know it is funny
because when it came out and I had
shaved my head you know came out on
television and that they go oh it's the
new how even though it's nothing like
the old Howie Mandel yeah I've never
been allowed to be outside from onstage
you know I got my ears pierced in the
70s I don't wear earrings now I'm not
into wearing earrings now but you know I
got them pierced in the 70s and I've
always had to change and dress
differently than I actually am and I
don't do that anymore do you think that
experience with the daytime show is what
would kind of got you to that point
where you're like look I'm not I'm not
do this again I'm not fall in the same
spot where I'm just doing what everyone
expects me I'm gonna do what I want to
do and my thing you know the truth is
this is an amazingly wonderful business
but it is such an emotionally
debilitating business you know as you
guys were just talking about you know
somebody comes up and says yeah you're
great and then yeah but you have the
option now for the roller ghoster are
sorry yeah they're really hard because
you got all these self-doubt you know
how he came up to me and said this was
great he's never seen it and they didn't
call me back tomorrow and there's
somebody but that's what this business
here and it killed you know I have my
own mental health issues as it is so
this doesn't I don't know that this
helps me it's just I'm more medicated
than I've ever been so that I don't but
but that's it they go you're perfect
we're giving you a show right but you
can't look like this you can't dress
like this you can't act like this you
got to pull you know earrings are
indicative of you know whatever changes
that need to be done and you know that
Howie Mandel was not obviously it's
always me but it's a portion of me Deal
or No Deal was the first time when I got
well I was really nervous I didn't want
to do it when I got called to do Deal or
No Deal yeah I was at the lowest point
of my career and my life you know I've
been rejected and I wasn't doing much
and I wasn't selling a lot of tickets
and then I got a call we want you to
host a game show and I don't know if you
could put yourself back in 2004 and 2005
but comedians did not do games right
he's a punch line for a comic was the
game show host you know you made fun of
that with the iron man so you know you
didn't want to be and it was probably
considered the lowest rung you know like
this you do features yeah you do
television you do commercials yeah and
you do game shows and when they asked me
to do it I said no I said no three times
until my wife saw that I was in a like
you know a tailspin mentally and said
hey listen you just got to get out of
the house and do something and I went
and did that show the planning I had for
that show what I wrap my head around was
you know no comedians have done shows
except the last time comedians have done
game shows was Groucho Marx oh yeah far
but that's what it was and Johnny Carson
did right before he did this Tonight
Show but before that somebody who had a
comedy career who went into an Pacific
comedy nobody so I I asked them for can
I hire somebody to write with me I had
these ideas you know because again I was
really scared it was going to be short
of that 15 hours that we spent it was
going to be one hour
I'm just saying open the kit there's no
game there's no skill there's no no it's
just me so yeah it's writing on you and
and I thought okay I can be funny
there's something so I had all these
plans and what happened was I'll never
forget I got the picture right here
somewhere I'll show T but I had the
picture I'll never forget to her name
her name's Karen van was the very first
contestant and after all this practicing
the they roll tape and they go Howie
Mandel and I go Deal or No Deal and then
I look and I'm standing as close as I am
to you guys right now to a real person
to karen van and karen van i asked her a
question about herself
and and she tells me she's got three
children she has no health insurance
she's never owned a home and at that
time again in 2005 besides Who Wants to
Be a Millionaire a million dollars was
huge and it still is you know but I mean
nobody had really there hadn't been
Marinette prize million dollars on TV
number one number two for somebody who
doesn't live in LA that by three
lifetimes of yeah comfort you know it
buys you know many homes cars insurance
your your life has changed forever so
having talked to her and looking at her
and seeing the kids in the background
you also you guys have been on sets for
those that haven't been on sets which is
most contestants on game shows when
they're in the center of it yeah you
notice a glaze comes over somebody and
it's a glaze of oh my god I'm in another
world end cameras there's 300 people
yeah there's I'm in Hollywood I've never
been in Hollywood and then I thought as
I looked at her you know the first offer
came in and the first offer so I was
always like 10 or 20 thousand dollars
and think about this and your juice me a
thousand dollars sure ten thousand
dollars and I looked at her in that and
I could tell that she wasn't listening
listen glaze over
she's glazed over and I thought I can't
do
a joke and I can't because I don't want
to be you know I wasn't listening I
didn't realize what he said so it became
more about you know I'm a human first
before I'm a comedian I got it you know
Karen you're sitting there with you
three kids there's an offer here and
that state changed my cadence yet I
would go twenty thousand dollars Deal or
No Deal I go really do you hear me
twenty thousand dollars well you have to
open up another four cases twenty you
know and really it was everything short
of just grabbing her by the neck and
going are you out of your [ __ ] mind
you have been over ten minutes yes
you've done nothing to do have nothing
you live in Middle America twenty
thousand dollars is a down payment on a
home sure it's your rent for the next
ten you take the [ __ ] twenty one
dollars I know you've already won you
know jeopardy these people who study for
a year they're lucky if they walk out
with six thousand dollars seven is one
three thousand dollars and I threw
everything by the wayside like all my
comedy and everything and it was just
like the truest form the first time I've
ever been on television just being a
human being being myself being a father
being a husband being and after I
finished taping it I was so embarrassed
because I said I didn't as we know as
comics you know we kind of create and
plan and have a closing and the ending
is what I'm gonna do and I wasn't
outrageous and I was just myself it was
like I bared myself naked I had empathy
because another human being had that and
when it was going to air I flew to off
the you know out of North America but
you know I to get away I didn't want to
be here I didn't want to be made fun of
and I started getting texts you know do
you know what the ratings were last
night and then the next night they
played five nights in a row the next
night they went up the next night they
went up and it became this phenomena
yeah and I landed back in Miami and
within 30 seconds somebody came up to me
when hey Deal or No Deal it was like a
catchphrase yeah when oh my god it was
that I was so embarrassed of it it was
not expected Wow I did it on a you know
because my wife wanted to get me out of
the house and I was like flailing
mentally and
it was the only time that I've ever been
without humor true to myself and after
that there was a plethora of game shows
the next one was who martyr than a 5th
grader Jennifer yeah and then which we
call it Bob Saget did the hundred that's
right one versus a hundred and then you
know the and then we could talk about
through Kerry and Justine RV all these
other people that have been Raymond
Pollock and waiting ready and yeah they
went in mind you know comedians but
before that it was nothing and it kind
of changed my life and you know I've
known that is somebody who had done you
know 22 tonight shows with Johnny Carson
you know I realized you know I used to
really be particular about the sets that
I was putting together and I go on this
is my joke and the throw away when I was
sitting on the counter well on the couch
was what America would glom on to the
next day yeah yeah the throw away you
know as I got known in the early 80s or
the late 70s is the guy that put the
rubber glove on my head right that came
out of being on stage and going blank
and not having anything to do and I have
OCD and I was carrying gloves and I just
put on my head I start breathing the
fingers were blowing up and that this
was not something that I ever thought
would be a closer this is not something
I ever dreamed would buy me my house
this is not something that I ever
thought I would be known for yet you
don't know right and that's why you know
Here I am in my 60s you know saying that
if I had to give anybody any opportuni
advice it is you don't know you can't
plan just say okay just walk through
every door some doors are just going to
be you know a pile of [ __ ] and you're
going to step in there but what you're
going to learn from that is I'm not
going to go through that door again
right but just every open door walk
through you know our instinct is not you
know when we think about something it
doesn't help us there's no thought is
not a good thing we are an instinctual
animal and you know Nike has that phrase
just do it and that's what I learned you
know and I also learned that if I ever
did another daytime show going back to
your question it wouldn't look anything
or be anything like the one you saw
right it might not be successful but I
tell you that I would
approach it totally differently and I
would be very comfortable in just being
myself and whether it works you just
throw yourself out that's what life is
and we're all you know we're all
unperfect that we all have our issues we
all have just throw yourself out there
and it's going to work
and that's why even you know you call me
and you say do you want to be in a park
yes I'd like to do a pond let's do it
you know and I'll say let's do it to
anything anywhere anytime I'll go to a
concert at a theater now you know in
some state I do you know 200 a year and
then I find out if I'm still up if
there's a club in the area I'll drop in
on the club I don't know what's going on
promise what's going to happen and
that's what life is right at it
life's too short well it is the right
way you asked anybody who's ever had any
success they just did it thank you right
do you still do like you know it's
opening because Steve and I are at a
level much lower in terms of like you go
to comedy clubs they're always screwing
you over
they're always shorting the bonuses
they're near they won't give you a hotel
they won't do this but you would look at
you and you're like you're at a level
now where you can kind of call all the
shots do you still feel like you're
still fighting all the time with
executives and kind of like no and in
fact you say your level in my level
we're not it here's my I have three
children grandchildren and this is what
I said the level is success success is
the ability to find something that
you're passionate about you're
successful in life to reach the whatever
you deem the paycheck that is successful
or whatever whatever you think the know
to write that all goes away
you know we all are heading to the same
place and nobody's the richest guy in a
graveyard you know it and you could be
as big as the you know I can't imagine
anybody as big as the Beatles or the
notoriety of the Beatles huh my
grandkids have no idea who they are
their fame doesn't so success is
something from within finding that
comedy you want to do you're just as
successful as I am if you want to go
outside yourself I have bigger fights
than you have
I am dissed more than you are I am an
I'll tell you why because you'd think
after I had a series and after I had
this that would always think the next I
was going to know that I wouldn't get
treated this way it's a bigger slap you
know they don't want to take a meeting
they say no they cancelled they don't
want to give you they offer you what you
half of what you got on the last show
really after what I did all right on
Deal or No Deal I'm going to get offered
half yes I get offered happen so I am
I'm humiliated harder and more than you
on you are at a better level family
beliefs I you know so to the point is
and you have the ability to do a show
now at this level you know I came up in
the 70s when I couldn't do a podcast
right I would have loved the the
opportunity to say okay I can go get a
guest on the show and I can go do a show
today because I want to do a show do you
know how many hoops I have to go to go
do a show I can't do a show so so you
don't look at anybody else to kind of
measure your success your success is
you've got up in the morning if you're
excited and I don't care if you're
excited about your [ __ ] stamp
collection if you've got three stamps
you have the ability you're alive today
and you have three [ __ ] stamps right
and this is my collection right and you
may have 200 stamps but I got 300 and I
love my stamps and I spend time with my
stamps and I just can't wait to get home
from work from cleaning shift to look at
my stamps that's success because there's
so many people in this world right now
who hate every minute of their life yeah
and that's not success and I don't care
how much money they have and the
connotation of hump day is Wednesday
when they are halfway through doing the
[ __ ] they don't want to be doing to
maybe get to the weekend where they
don't have to do that [ __ ] but there's
nothing really exciting happen not wait
it's just like nothing and I'll tell you
something I would have been when I found
stand-up comedy which was April 9th
April 19 1977 at Yuk Yuk's you know it
was in the heart of the and I was in
retail business it was in the heart of
the disco craze I didn't like disco I
don't like dancing I'm not a disco
person and I went to this club because
it opened up and I thought oh my god
this is the end the guy Mark Breaux
it was the host said any amateurs want
to get up and try it on Monday night I
went okay I'll do it and I went and did
it you know and the first time I got
enveloped by a laugh and one lap a lot
of it didn't work I thought oh my god
I'm home
yeah or what Emmett and I wasn't getting
paid and I dropped down there every
night of the week and just to watch
other comics and there's other narrative
wells for lack of a better you know that
people who wanted to put themselves out
there and act goofy or bare their soul
or whatever this was so different in
that time that was the the I was in the
middle of the boom of comedy from the
catcher rising stars to the improv stew
the you know the yuk-yuk still it was
amazing and I was so happy and I promise
you if I would have went to a shitty job
every day but once a week I could get
that like people like to get together
with the ads and play cards I don't play
card so people like to have a you know
basketball game at the Y if I could have
that even today and I have another job I
made it yeah right and and the fact that
I'm here in van nuys
in an office is just because I
continually say yes to things that don't
really make sense to sometimes seem like
really bad ideas but I say yes and I've
done some really bad idea you talk about
this is how we officially should never
do another hot let me just say this how
you should go out of the country when we
drop this body when you come back in
they'll be like gentleman so Chuck
recover it's just interesting because
you know we look at a guy like you and
I'm sure a lot of people do and they see
you and all your success and they know
I'm sure people from the outside looking
in say well there's a guy that has
everything and doesn't you have all the
things yeah it doesn't have all the
things you mentioned and then you know
the way you pointed out that's never
totally dealing with their own demons
and issues and because I would think you
you can get whatever you want you could
call up and get a meeting immediately
you could do this and you could do that
and then you know you're saying no I
mean everybody's out for their own
agenda they really are and it's not as
easy I mean I'm not complaining I think
I'm you know I I have everything I've
ever dreamed of and more but just to say
that I don't get kicked in the nuts five
times a week would be
wrong and you know I do try to get
people on the phone that I can't get on
the phone I do try to sell things that I
can't sell I do want to do things that
nobody's offering me right you know at
all the time and that's just business
and then aside from business my own
demons I'm a mess
you know I'm medicated as we speak we're
all in this we're all we all have our
own humility in humanity and I deal with
anxiety and depression and all the time
there isn't a there isn't a hump to get
over where you go oh my god so this is
what it's all green pasture humility
humanity being a human being is tough
you know there's a t-shirt I didn't make
it up [ __ ] happens it happens to all of
us yeah it's there's a great story in
the movie comedian with Seinfeld where
he said that that band there was a band
that was traveling don't know plane or
their bus got caught in the mud they
were they were going to a gig like on
Christmas they were dragging all their
equipment through this this mud and this
rain and they came upon a house that was
like this Swiss Family Robinson house
and they looked in and be war I bought
yeah there was a fire going and they
were all gather around the table playing
a board game and it's just this great
typical middle American family one of
the band members looks and he's like how
do people live like that it's like
because they got to do they were doing
what they wanted to do and it was
absolutely crazy to just think do you
get to do speaking of people you know
disagreeing do people tweet you like hey
I can't believe you didn't like that
person on a GT I can't believe that you
did you know is not doing this in this
day and age and I talk always with other
comedians social media is a blessing and
a curse
yes and it's a blessing because when I
was coming up there was one stage to go
to you had that you needed time at The
Comedy Store or The Improv right you're
only in LA really - yeah to get to that
next level to get somebody on television
to see you and that was it now you know
with social media you could post a
podcast you could post a video what do
you say that because last night we're
talking about the prep for this and
social media and I said I think Howie
let's talk to him about the difference
when he started - now I think I mean
this is the ultimate compliment you
would have it's the stuff that was
around today was around when you started
you would have been like a vine star
with the
the videos like well I like the idea
ever yeah but then again you have to do
there's a lot of things I'll you know
I'm an insomniac and I do but I live on
social media and I live and I look at
all these things yeah but it's also what
is going to break through you don't know
it's so noisy out there and there's so
much stuff and and to be honest with you
a lot of the stuff I don't even really
understand if I becomes as big as it is
I remember like the one of my favorite
things you've ever noticed that the
behavior one of your specials or maybe
it was interspersed because you're on
the beach I think and why and you're
yelling after people then they're
turning around right yeah and it's just
exactly what you would expect on like a
video that now some kid who who's never
done comedy whatsoever but by this get a
million okay and I think you're asking
yeah I'm also open and everybody is yeah
to be hit so hard so negatively so you
know I have know how they're you know I
know that Jimmy Kimmel does this thing
mean tweets but the react you know I
think I'm opening up my Twitter as we
speak I will find within you can't read
from daily without it now in reading
something horrible and and personal and
you know and maybe even dangerous you
know like I'm looking as we as we speak
but it'll be in the top few quick lies
and does it affect you I mean is it is
it like something like I mean well
you've been in the business I'll tell
you what affects me and not people
saying bad things what affects me is and
I've talked about this with Chris Rock
and and other people is the ability for
you know they call social media well
first of all you're not you know media
the connotation media it used to be like
a newspaper man somebody in radio
somebody in television some idiot alone
in his underpants in his room becomes
media but you can you can say something
that can snowball the art of comedy what
I loved about the art my biggest
influence ever in comedy and you can't
you wouldn't be able to tell from
knowing me and knowing what I do is
Richard Pryor and I'll tell you what
Richard Pryor besides him being brillian
he was the guy when I first came out
here in the 70s I watched him write live
on the Sunset Strip and I watched him
show up every night there were crowds of
people just wanting to just catch a
glimpse of this but he showed up on
stage every night trying out material
Paul Mooney was off to the side writing
down his stuff and then they'd sit and
talk about it and hone it but the brave
the bravery that he had to and he was
already a star yeah you know he's done
movies the the bravery he had to throw
[ __ ] out there against a wall and maybe
it not worked maybe it was even really
offensive maybe somebody's jaw would
drop not because they thought it was
funny but how the [ __ ] could you say say
something like that but I that was the
first time I thought that's what these
comedy clubs are for you know I'd come
up an amateur night and and that gave me
the ability and that's why even to this
day I will want to drop in after a
concert if there's three people in the
room I want to just try something
because ultimately we sitting in our
homes or wherever we're sitting or in
your studio in Burbank you have an idea
but until you share that idea with an
audience you really don't know like I've
always contended that you know people go
to the comedy clubs at Amateur Night
they see horrible horrible comedy but
nobody's there on their own nobody shows
up there just because unless they're
totally delusional and they have a
mental health problem somebody is there
because they have a friend or an aunt at
the Thanksgiving table you're so funny
you can't try it so it's the luck of the
draw it's really luck that your
sensibility in your sense of humor is
shared by a wider swath than just your
uncle yeah yeah you know and that's what
I will never say to anybody even in
America's Got Talent
that's not funny I could say I don't get
it I could say that doesn't tickle my
you know this like for any art form so
the beauty was that he was throwing [ __ ]
out there because like a painter who
shades you know if you throw the first
paint on the canvas you see like a black
dot on the canvas you go that's not a
what is that well then you see that he
puts some red in it and then there's
some shading and then you see he adds
something else to it then there's a
it's this beautiful tree and it grows
and comedy isn't much unlike that yeah
you know you throw a word or you have a
concept but you didn't hit it right and
I should close with this and I should do
that what happens now in this day of an
age of social media number one we can't
throw that black piece of paint out
because it could be politically
incorrect somebody in the audience could
have a phone could record you could lose
your whole career number one number two
they could just record you and that goes
out there and it's an unfinished piece
look at his painting of comedy and not
good it's really hard to like experiment
and be totally open and be free-spirited
without the concern that this is going
to get out there and the more notoriety
you have and I'm not going to say
success but the most more you know if I
drop in on the club and I just want to
try something outrageous I can't really
do that and feel okay because it may be
stupid and it may not work I used to be
I watched Richard Pryor be fearless
I'm not fearless anymore there was a
time when I was but I'm not fearless
anymore because I don't know what
context I controlled the context in the
Sandi's in the early eighties I don't
control it now that's that's interesting
you you still go out I remember I've run
into it maybe definitely once maybe
twice it like the Third Street Playhouse
in Santa Monica the comedy show there
drop it hop in and do sets and I still
do it because I don't know you loved it
I loved it and I loved the process of
creating yeah not only getting the laugh
but finding the funny and you know
finding I have an idea but I don't know
and the only way that I can really hone
it is I need an audience yeah
assemblance of an audience you know
doesn't even happen it doesn't have to
be a hundred people maybe eight people
but I need that young people who don't
know me and don't know I just want to
try and I want to try it I'll drop in on
that Club and then the same night if I'm
doing that I'll drop in on four
different clubs right and try the same
thing and maybe change the word and hone
it and think about it even though it
seems like I'm very improvisational and
I'm willing to be improvisational and go
off the cuff I really take my comedy
really seriously and try to do that but
in this day and age of social media
besides the mean
they're all so mean in about the art
form yeah about the political
correctness about the you know it's just
a scary time it really is never
wondering that to like with a GT you see
a comic come out they do ninety seconds
don't you have to immediately think like
can this person let's say they win the
whole thing you're thinking always
bigger pictures this person a million
dollar act can this person I know that
I'm seeing ninety seconds but can this
person do an hour on a Late Show Friday
night at a club like I mean obviously
like a time I thought it was a headliner
I don't know I kind of here's that
here's what I try to get across to my
cohorts and even people on on in the
audience at home watching I have respect
for every comedian you know it was Jerry
Seinfeld kind of talked about the first
time I think it was a the Aspen Comedy
Festival he was receiving an award and I
don't did you ever see him his speech
about the award he said as a comic were
not used to receiving awards were
usually at the end of the show you know
maybe sometimes were invited to sit down
and look at the couch nobody really
gives it you know it's really funny
because the biggest award in show
business is an Oscar and think about an
actor what is it act to do an actor gets
picked up from his house they'll go to a
set where they'll dress you they'll comb
your hair they put maybe a mask on you
or some makeup then they go put a piece
of tape on the floor and they say what I
need you to do is walk in stop at that
tape and then here's what I want you to
say there's no thought you're going to
memorize words that they tell you to say
so they tell you to say that you walk in
you say that make oh no not great cut
try it again and maybe you'll try it
like 200 times and then they'll put
another piece of tape because they want
to shoot it from another angle then
somebody will go into an edit Bay and
cut all the angles so it looks very
different than what happened that day
but it looks that and then one night
they go [ __ ] brilliant here's an
award where a comedian sits alone writes
his own script creates his own character
dresses himself and needs to elicit from
an audience a huge response every 30
seconds because of it
really quiet and he doesn't get that or
she doesn't get that then he realizes
that maybe it's not working so he needs
to make it work he's got it so on a GT
somebody comes out and sings an aria on
a grande song well you have a nice voice
and you're singing their song but then
the comic comes out and everybody is
willing really quickly to go not funny
not good bye you know the truth is that
and that what about comedians and comics
the difference being that you know one
says funny things and one says things
funny you know if you've created a
character that's really likable I may
not respond or understand your reference
I may not even get what your joke is but
I understand what goes into it and how
hard it is to be here and the criteria
for our show is not to be able to do in
our set you don't have to do it you've
come to an hour you know I'm the same
guy that had the three minutes set and
that's all I had and I didn't even have
a set you know I made it I made it big
and I got pretty big saying what what
what and rolling rubber glove on my head
and what was you know that came out of
me just not understanding what they were
I came out on stage and I was so
phonetic I'm so scared yeah and and I
went okay okay okay okay and I was
trying to remember and that's like
giggling at me I'm going to what what
what what and then they started giggling
more and my what you know my material
and my persona came from the audience
came from real fear real being
inquisitive and not really understanding
not having anything to do so I just
pulled a rubber glove on my head so what
I'm saying is I'm not going to judge
material as much as I'll judge are you a
character that I want to see again and
can you you know and I don't even judge
by is that worthy of a show in Vegas I
judge that 90 seconds or that planet you
got something I don't know what it is
you're kind of funny I didn't I didn't
particularly laugh at what because it's
not my world whatever it is you were
talking about and I don't know you know
for me comedy is about relating you know
something embarrassing happen that's why
I hate jokes I hate hate
when somebody comes up to me and says I
gotta tell you a joke ey Ronnie no you
know two guys walk into a bar no they
didn't you know my my basis of humor is
off of reality awkwardness and
discomfort you know so I don't I don't
remember what the question was
but the truth is that judging comedy I
try to educate everybody to understand
how many levels in how hard that's their
material it's their time they're naked
there's no band they need to elicit a
lot more than somebody who sings a song
and then gets an applause at the end
because that's what you're going to get
or even if you're asking them to clap
along to your rhythm we need so much
more as comedians and get that in 90
seconds if they got three less it's hard
to laugh right if it's hard but you
can't just tell somebody to really
laughing yeah who was a comic that did
the show that you were disappointed
didn't go further um you know didn't go
further maybe I have a you know the kind
of comics that I personally respond to
are the kind of comics that I believe
are you know I loved like Andy Kaufman
and that kind of comedy now you could
say there's no I don't know that America
responds to that in the you know as much
as they respond to you know classic
material right the masses maybe don't
get mad it is I like that we have we
have a comic on this season that I
absolutely love do you know who Jeffrey
the good boy of comedy is no no I'm
excited
wait wait till you see him yeah but I
wonder if America will respond it
because it's just a weird character yeah
well one of the people I was thinking of
even as you were talking about it
they're just you were saying not even
the jokes and she's a fantastic joke
writer but like Wendy Liebman on the
show you just get a feeling when she's
onstage right you're like I like this
person if she's like the hole and you
want to spend time right listen to her
you know whether but comedy is so narrow
to me you know you know what I'm saying
it's kind of like music you know in the
sense that and that's why I've always
though my golden budget last year had
originals grace Vanderwall but I've
always contended that the best thing and
I thought with Howard when he was on the
show that if you want to win this it's
made basically a popularity contest if
you're going to already pick a top 40
song and you have it's not a good chance
and went your if everybody already loves
this song you know comedians can't do
that right I can't just come on and do
it George Carlin or Rodney Dangerfield
routine and if they were allowed to just
recite it and it was good there's a good
chance they would win but then you'd go
hey maybe funny media yeah yeah and
you'd go that's not your material that's
not your wasn't there initially thinking
of which wasn't there an issue with a
comic who then the warm up said that he
story this yes and as the comic was
getting Greg who I know right there was
an issue with that right yeah so in the
middle of taping the warm-up guy came
out as he was doing it singing that to
my act like I don't I don't know if that
if that was the case because also having
been in this business for a long time it
is very possible that if you're thinking
along funny lines there are chances that
there's another funny person that came
up with the same rent with the same joke
you know I did I did this this WWE event
almost two years ago I think I did it
and right after Donald Trump announced
his candidacy and I said and and this
was like far before you even thought
that he had a chance it was kind of
money that he announced was gone and and
I remember on that you could look it up
it's on tape I remember on that I said
can you imagine if he's in the White
House it brings a whole new meaning to
orange is the new black that's in at
that time I've heard maybe a half a
dozen comics use that exact same line
yeah I don't think anybody stole stole
my bit
I think that's an obvious way to go his
orange was out there that is a show
you're thinking of iconic ideas
you know so the truth of the matter is
yeah you know I even remember the bit
that you're talking about the car
driving yes inside a closed window
watching two people argue yes but we've
all been in you know the reason that got
huge laughs and did really well even for
Frank is because we've seen that right
is it possible that more than one comic
like I don't know what their
relationship is and how Emma I don't
know the guy that was on our show but is
it possible that more than one comic has
been out in traffic seeing that and
thought that's a great bit right to here
psyche it's always possible right so in
what happened as a result of that did he
because I thought that Frank then went
to the producers that this is my bit and
then that guy got caught or something
like that from what I remember I don't
know what happened interest I swear I
don't know what happened but I you know
well like you said watch watch the
late-night shows on any given night
there's always that parallel thinking
where found do jokes Imbler is Conan or
you know they're all doing yeah they're
others they're all doing that and by the
way speaking of AGT how was the new
dynamic now with Tyra Banks hosting
because I know that you were obviously
very close with Nick Cannon I am and
he's a lamb and I still talk to him you
know I'm very I was heartbroken at the
fact that he decided to move on because
if it ain't broke don't fix it my show
was number one in the summer but I also
respect his integrity for you know doing
what he wants to do creatively and he is
very busy and he's doing well and I just
started working with Tyra and I got to
tell you she's amazing yeah she really
has a great sense of humor she knows
comedy she's stunning and listen we just
talked about people's heart being broken
on our stage you know sometimes if they
don't go on what better way place to go
than to be coddled
but I really think so my god I just want
to be a short man I needs a hug it can't
be better for you tune out the shows out
here in LA right that you're not
cross-country commuting amazingly yeah
you're hey you know me at my age at this
time in my career it's so great to just
get into a car and drive to work and
then drive home and when we were in New
York though I love Howard and I love New
York and I love Radio City Music Hall
you know when we were doing the live
shows I was commuting so ever
a Wednesday and Thursday I'd fly in and
then fly back right you know I do enough
flying as it is as I said do 200 dates a
year the reason I'm in Van Nuys because
I'm right by the airport here so I can
have this podcast get on a plane right
this week I get on a plane and fly out
and then come back and have my meetings
and do my business and yeah I'm trying
to make things as easy as possible we we
could keep you here all day but we want
to start wrapping up because I mean
obviously you're so busy but we have so
many things I would even I are such huge
Howard Stern fans huge and what could
you're always fantastic on can you just
share that story and you shared it on
stir and I just want our listeners to
hear where you're in high school and you
call it the construction company to do
like like a builder to get work done on
the school oh yeah and I've always I
came to comedy well I want to set up
where why I thought and it didn't work
for me but there was always comedy in my
house and my parents always laughed and
always watched The Tonight Show Jack
Paar and they always watch and they and
my dad used to buy comedy albums and
then bring them home and I used to see
my mom and my dad they throw on this
record or they'd watch TV and they'd be
laughing and I was 3 or 4 years old and
I'd walk in and everybody's laughing and
you know that laughter is good but I
didn't get it you know and even if I
watch the comic you know Tiger they said
something about a mother I don't even
know what a mother-in-law is yeah yeah
the first time I recollect that I could
join the party was and he's my hero was
Allen Funt on candid camera
and I sat at the at my parents feet they
were watching Sunday night they are
watching candid camera and he explained
he didn't that you could be 2 years old
and understand this that I'm gonna hire
somebody who thinks they're going to be
a receptionist they're going to answer
the phone and every time the phone rings
that they can't miss a call they were
told and they reach for the phone I got
a rope attached to the desk that goes in
the wall there's guys on the other side
and when she goes to reach for the phone
we're going to pull the rope and the
desk is going to go away right so I kind
of understood and that was like a
surprise party and this isn't really a
lot of excitement in my living room just
in that moment the first time they put
somebody there the phone rang she goes
and reaches it they pay the rope and the
desk is gone and the awe on her face
it was the most guttural wonderful last
ever said by my mom my dad and me all
together and I went oh my god I love
this I love to laugh it's comedy again
remember four or five years old no
understanding that you need a TV show
right an audience so that became I tried
to always recreate that and then I
became my own little Allen Funt without
a show now I can't sit I've been
diagnosed with OCD and ADHD later on in
life but I you know I can't sit and I
wasn't the class clown in as far as you
know having the witty response but I
would always set these things up because
I knew it was funny yeah I just never
shared so I thought it was funny one day
to sit in class and I was on the second
or third floor in math class and I had
called the yellow pages I'd always done
like prank calls alone I didn't have any
friends you know and I called the yellow
pages and I said you know we're getting
an addition onto the library and I think
your company I called a construction
company I'd like you to give us I'd like
to expand it you know 20 feet into the
field and you give it a bid and can you
come tomorrow can you come at three
o'clock I knew when I was going to be in
class but you must have done it at home
right because I we said there was no
phones but you know she went back home
and did this no I made an appointment
for the time of my so that I would sit
not telling any friends that's how
different I I didn't tell any friend I'm
sitting a mascot I couldn't concentrate
I look out the window and I'm just
enjoying myself this guy with a tape
measure he's measuring her to the field
and he's got you know a belt like a
little tool belt he's writing things
down on his clipboard and then I see the
principal go out I can't hear what's
going on I see that or the vice
principal go out and talk to him and I
see him doing it and I know that I had
given my name I've in my name and
everything and I feel funny and I'm
really enjoying that like I never did
before lo and behold within minutes you
know I get a will Howard man Belle
please come down to the office I go down
to the office and to me this is also
funny because the principal is saying
you know I was just outside and
the gentleman has your name he said that
you've authorized an addition on to our
library and I said that is not true and
he said well he said he has your name I
said no no no no I'm getting three bids
and then it was really fun there's
nobody there and I don't have an
audience and really like almost like I
was dangerous the guy comes back he goes
could you could you just have a seat
here and I'll be back in just a couple
of minutes and he goes into the office
as it turns out he called my parents and
told my parents to come right down yeah
and my parents come right down and
they're sitting there and then now I'm
sitting in the room and they said you
know you're your son authorized in
addition on to the library and it was
just like this and that's what I love
more than laughter I love awkward
silence and business and I could see my
mom biting her lip and like I don't know
what he expected to hear from her my
mother like we told him never to put an
addition on to the library I'm told he
is an authorized to hire construction
come and like what did he I don't know
what he wanted but it was just quiet and
eventually I got asked to leave the
school and they called in psychologist
and and and their recommendation is this
that I had behavioral problems I got
thrown at three different schools for
all different events like this and
people you know this became here saying
this was funny because people will come
up to me now you were so funny in school
but I didn't have a friend in school
because the you know I was just deemed
insane like just I would do these crazy
things and not for a laugh just how he
really believed and I kind of liked that
folklore of believing you know that
people were a little afraid of me and I
was you know I saw people pointing at me
and talking about me so that was my own
little notoriety when I was a kid but
funny I just love that idea that idea
that you called about the extension for
the library and then like a day later
you've almost forgotten about like
you're just like sitting in the
classroom and then you see them
measuring and they're like oh that's
right but I thought it was but the
bigger part of it is it's like I was the
audience me you're and drop my whole
throughout my whole life and even now
when I do things you know my wife and my
mom have always said to me like where's
the joke
to choke on Holi they just think you're
an idiot and I go I'm okay with that yes
I really am okay with that I am more
than getting a laugh more than when
somebody is looking at me and going what
really what just happened to me that I
find that so much write funnier so much
more exciting so much more what a
discomfort and you know I live because
of my mental health problems in a very
awkward uncomfortable world so I'm very
comfortable in discomfort and
awkwardness and if you think about
comedy really
it's always about somebody else's
misfortune the [ __ ] you know when the
two guys walk into a bar something
embarrassing happens to one one idea you
know I just like to be in control of
what happens to that person right you
know or somebody gets a pie in the face
you're laughing it they're a clown falls
down you're laughing at their misfortune
and they're awkward and they're
uncomfort and I just I like to create
that world that's what I love hidden
cameras my favorite thing is I find it
Mike relatable comedy yeah there are
people who will say it's mean why are
you doing that it's not really mean
because truth be told were all human and
it brings all of us through the same
level right we all believe whatever is
being said to us we all believe the
situation we're in and we all react
differently and let's just watch you
know nobody's better than anybody and
we're all there to you know if we can't
have fun and we can't laugh at it we're
just going to cry right and be angry and
and fight comedy is a great and laughter
is a great bridge to sanity yeah and
that's why you still love doing all the
road dates I mean it's just a chance for
you to just break out be on your own I
will never stop doing that because also
it also gets me into the real world you
know living in LA or New York and
working in production
I like behind the scenes as much as I
love you don't meet this is not a real
world and people here in this community
aren't real but when you're in the
middle of Iowa right now you're and even
through their sensibility of what
they're relating to and laughing at you
really get a sense of the people you're
writing for performing for making TV for
making movies
or that's America right when you're in
that moment being at the Beverly Center
here in LA is not America right nobody
really looks like anybody else right you
know it's I'm not surprised by anything
anymore because I really I'm out there
and I spend more time in front of
America than I do in front of people in
New York Miami and LA right you know and
I kind of know who I'm catering to well
we start wrapping up because you have
such a busy schedule but I just want to
say this when I worked at AGT for those
six days down the road what I loved was
you were the only judge that would have
dinner with the crew the only guy that
would go out and have drinks with the
crew at the end of the night it really
felt like you just loved being part of
hanging with everybody everybody else is
back in their dressing room everybody
which is kind of doing their own thing
and you're well maybe maybe they may
probably need it to rest or lie down Ida
can't lie down and I like being a lot
around Pete yeah you are you are yeah
you're not the guy used to like you were
talking about the Beverly Center you're
not the typical guy you think oh I'm
going to I'm going to see Howie Mandel
from the from the bus he's going to be
walking into you know the coffee shop to
get his thing you and Gary and I have
seen you like walking across Santa
Monica in a wave and yeah I'm at Denny's
four times a week I saw Billy I saw you
the night before I did Letterman you
were on Letterman and I was doing the
show as a comic I the next day and I
tell you at the deli and I was at having
dinner with my mom and you came over to
talk to us for a couple minutes I mean
you're you're one of the nicest guys
yeah thank you I don't know that I'm the
nicest guy but I'm a normal guy that's
right what AM normal with i abnormal
necessity yeah well we're excited I know
that you said season 12 has a comic
coming up that we should be looking at
or I love this yeah yeah and that's good
a premiere in the summer it's a great
summer job hard to make 30th I know we
got a wrap up but is there eat people
always say you always want to like us we
always want the next level and that kind
of thing people always say if you could
have a career whose would it be you have
one of those careers where you've seem
to have done so much like you listed at
the beginning and then all the stuff
like you said that you you attempt is
there something you haven't done yet
that you still want to that I'm sure
there's a ton of things that I have
then yeah yeah and I want to be asked to
do them yeah that's everything
Sharon owned everything yeah whatever it
is you know and that's how my in and I
hope that somebody thinks of me and and
doesn't overthink it
oh we can't afford him are you too busy
or he doesn't that the people will still
call and I need to do things yeah I
think the ones the one question we got
over and over again on Facebook was uh
is is Bobby's world coming back I'm
trying
yeah so I've made some deals with some
partners and hopefully we can get that
finger strong we can lock it yeah I love
it I'd like to do that I'd like to do
more of that kind of stuff I'd like to
do more television I'd like to do film
you know I I'm in a little Netflix thing
right now I just directed a on Hulu you
can get that committed it's a
documentary I did over 20 years with a
fellow comic I followed him the Kohen
it's committed so I love directing I'm
doing a another documentary I did a
Netflix small shots I got to play a
little character they called me to act
this okay I'll do it you know your other
shows on Spike to karaoke karaoke
showdown yep
is with Craig Rob yeah I produced that
so I produce a lot of things that I'm
not in I like producing that's what this
office that you're sitting in right now
is that's what and obviously being on
this show I mean I'm sure that that's
going to up your game yeah a lot of a
culture I start flying through night
result how long has this been on ah a
couple years yeah or you mean just this
right now just this particular broad 50
minutes yeah and we only usually go half
an hour really this is a testament to
you Howie yeah so thank you or you
haven't been able to think of a good end
you always want to leave Amana we don't
have Robbie we don't have a really oh
well that's it nothing you know you're
light you said you like those awkward
moments that's the ending to our show
not knowing not to do any more let you
sit quietly for a couple minutes and
then we'll kind of you know what let the
audience
turn it off instead of you usually the
podcaster says that's it and they're out
but you know what at this point we've
done enough right right so let's leave
it to the listener at any time from now
just if you turn it off yes
is something else yeah done we're done
nothing more is going to happen here
we're done and that's the recording
we'll keep going where we're finished
yes but we want them to be finished it's
cutting you hang up first you hey right
there yeah we into the fair sealer movie
where the guy came out and said movies
over with the first time he's ever done
that yeah I'm sorry but this is a
podcast that you do you think it has
half of the people that had been
listening ten minutes ago are gone now I
would like to think that they're still
here really yeah no I think they're
right because we haven't spewed anything
really interesting for the last minute
now hmm so I that's true so I think at
least 25% of the people that we're
listening 10 minutes ago are gone and
now what I'm gonna do is to be fair
you're a fantastic guest I've heard his
podcast before it's usually a lot of
uninteresting things though that doesn't
add a listener there are people that are
into uninteresting things right that's
what I mean I think that's his listeners
in Tetsu's right I've got in the real
song hasn't seen their collections in
attitude like I was interested so people
are just because something's not
interesting doesn't mean people won't
watch it
exactly and the art of it yeah but this
ending yeah this is less than not it oh
I see yeah below below this is a little
low uninteresting like you think we're
losing people right now I think we're
good it's not like oh yeah yeah I think
the opposite is going to happen really I
think there's gonna be people they have
those meters we're discussing who's
listening rather than my cussing
anything that's happened right right
which means ranking we had 80 other
questions that we never even got to but
the point is that I don't think they're
interested in themselves and we're
talking what can we take a caller no
there's no oh your paper bill no no no
no no no I don't mean in this in this
podcast can I go into another room and
take a phone call
yes yeah just do that I'm right I'm
gonna go do that it has nothing to do
with your podcast you sure yeah but
don't say goodbye don't say do should I
stop it you know we're just gonna do you
mind if we just we're gonna leave too
but well the equipment's gonna stay here
yeah we'll come back and pick it up
later just keep recording yeah so I'm
going the other room I'm gonna take
phone calls okay not from any listener
not for many fans or anything nothing no
I have a contractor that needs to call
me
something I'm doing you know one of the
rooms of my house okay and we thought
about of school know a lot of kids my
kids my daughter's probably going to
call me in a couple minutes
yes she wants to have lunch and then
Denny's
I do I go to Denny's four times a week
you do you love the Denny's I do love
that yeah I love the Grand Slam and I
can order the 55 and over menu to it and
they may be here at the Denny's yeah and
she's likes me she's a fan of mine and
sometimes she let's me sit in the
quinceanera room really well you get to
service I do by the way thank you so
much for doing this you're trying to say
goodbye now it's just awkward oh yeah as
I'm not leaving this is when that when
the host says goodbye and then the
guests won't leave right see people
always think of be fun to hang with me
but I'm the guide to party where you're
upstairs with your wife going woo tell
him to go want to go downstairs in a
vacuum
well why don't you just go back you
maybe I'll get in here yeah see you
later you